questo è un momento storico io penso di
non giocare a the peawees qua dentro da
madonna sarà da tipo gennaio del 2015
quando mi sono spostato a milano quindi
sono cinque anni anzi di più più di
cinque anni che io non gioco ha detto
visco ha dentro distanza mia se li
consentendo la parola ex miss russia
[Musica]
credo che i russi alle cose che devono
non siano così salutare ma è nel dubbio
l'ho saltato di end of debba come ora è
stato non riesco ad arrivarci una
barriera invisibile
ok quel poco che ho visto era una bomba
però visto proprio poco the twisters
lessicale della morte kingi mi incazzo a
jimmy che chi chi dovrebbe essere jimi
stop a pedalando senza le gambe
attaccate come possibile vabbè vabbè non
ha un senso tutto ciò ma va bene tutto
questo visto che mio figlio non mi dà
così tanto aiuto
credo che veramente l'obiettivo sia
farlo fuori come è possibile
va bene cava mons ok ok se seguisse lino
se questa linea non andare contro le
spine devi seguire il sellino pro vivo
dai
e vabbè per quale motivo ha fatto questa
cosa ah scusate devo vederlo per quale
motivo alla fine è successa questa cosa
hai fatto bungee jumping colto stomaco
aspetta ma perché c'è una bomba
[Musica]
bellissimo io non ho parole vi giuro ma
dai è fatto benissimo sto livello è
forse il più bel spy phone che io abbia
mai fatto
non sto scherzando piggy back rawhide
devo cavalcare il cosa cosa stop è una
cosa sto vedendo regalo cos'è sta roba
cos'è sta roba cosa ho lanciato una mia
gamba o miccoli lanciato sono un gamba
thrower cos'è successo si stano cosa sto
vedendo c'è un omino nave bellissimo
cosa sono i livelli di solito episodio
ragazzi pazzeschi c'è solo oggi ho fatto
istanza mi sa che sei vedendo è prevista
un botto di tempo l'onore di fidati non
è così bello in realtà è ultimata oggi
che così non so se sia emozionato che è
di nuovo camera mia però è veramente
strano ok oggi veramente un grandissimo
episodio buon trovo ora questo diventato
barbara michael trovi stanza mia bella
hai visto una che rimanga dentro parco
lemonia era così a posto giusto proprio
lui a palombella proprio lui aveva messo
anche il cursore della fine la palla
perfetta rock e dance è bello vederlo
prima cosa profeta che madonna altri 100
io
guido un razzo con le mie braccia
tutto a posto ma qual è l'obiettivo c'è
un traguardo livello o niente l'ho solo
guidare un razzo con le mie braccia
secondo me non c'è un traguardo però
voglio provare ad atterrare ragazzi
anche se non c'è una vera e propria
vittoria voglio provare ad atterrare
vivo perfetto scp o fammi vedere per
dire no è una dentiera scp questo c'è
una dentiera va giù madonna che scp
brutto aiuto laboratorio parte e una
dentiera che che che gira con un
coltello tubi continue berti che ne
avete un livello lungo era ora perché
tutti i cortili trovo the baby a ok ho
capito lei gol ma era facilissimo vita
ci ho messo un secondo e un mini
impossible è bellissimo
ora che ha fatto veramente bene il che e
veramente strano perché in genere
divertiti più distruttiva mete sono
fatti da cani invece con tanto di
spaccata la lisa fusco gravissimo totali
serpent questa vita di ruby
credo ma veramente ma basta è sempre
quello di prima che facevano nelle bolle
che devo tenermi sul sull'onda beh meno
male che il sempre non è uno sport
pericoloso almeno non sono spuntati gli
squali per ora è impossibile non tocca
la madonna è veramente difficile ragazzi
sembra facile ma di giocare un casino ok
dell'idea però ci ha avuto su tizio
ok ho mancato tipo tutte le monete che
c'erano cava bunga big kahuna di aiuto
c'è londra che si è schiantata sono
morto sono molto sulla spiaggia bombe
tiburon io chiedevo correre sopra la
televisione pensavo di dover scappare da
una televisione che mi seguiva di che
sarebbe stato molto frigi a posto
ok le raffaele invincibile questione più
livello spero che ti piaccia speriamo
vediamo un po cosa ho sbagliato a
prendere il personaggio aspetta
ciao fa vj poi sono talmente fosse video
grazie ciao amico maledizione questo hai
fatto veramente difficile amico mi ha
detto che devo capire perché hai messo
tutte robe ben strutturate a questa
volta teoricamente
sai cos'è che frega sono le frecce che
ti fanno rallentare non che ti ammazzano
quello che gli studi alle alpi con la
catena delle apa cosa me ne frega
la catena delle alpi il sistema montuoso
più amato d'italia e d'europa si estende
per 1.200 km di corda che cacchio me ne
frega e liguri al basso di gr
ma perché è questa cosa ma cosa vi
significa magari col tiro la marmolada
prima delle arti si trova le prealpi e
prima delle prealpi le tre prealpi dopo
le arti invece il post alti tipo il post
partita voglio farne un altro così per
favore poi gli iphone news
questo è il multi oraria perché non
avete cotto ma bellissimo questo studio
sulle alpi mi ha veramente cambiato la
vita
credo che dovrei partire sono morto
malissimo aiuto sono morto ma edizione
tipicissimo superare l'ostacolo tre
minuti ma ce l'ho fatta
hi fi dual good things that si sia morto
chi mi sarebbe luke ma fa niente ragazzi
chiamatelo come volete ma come ho
centrato il buco mai dire questa
partitura l'ambiente
[Musica]
da un giocatore chiamato igor miti e
tutto attaccato sono i forniti che sono
qui pupa
vabbè dai lasciamo ma cosa parlo a fare
una cosa parla scusatemi se non ho
viaggiato però la situazione è questa
prevedesse piaciuto come se io mi piace
anche ai social come in description era
è come sempre ci vediamo alla fosse
capito era ragazzi
[Musica]